Within a roughly 24 hour period, the Joe Biden
presidency took a major, major hit with Joe
Bob, Joe Biden, not Joe Balmer.
Joe Biden bombing Syria while appearing to
back away from requiring the inclusion of
a 15 dollar federal minimum wage in the covid
relief bill that's working its way through
Congress now on the minimum wage.
The Biden administration has come out and
said, we're still committed to that.
We might just do it outside of the covid relief
bill.
We'll get into that in a moment.
But not a good 24 hours for Joe Biden here.
On Thursday, Joe Biden launched airstrikes
in Syria.
Now, why did Joe Biden do this?
Well, he explained it or at least tried to.
In a letter to congressional leadership, Joe
Biden said the strike was, quote, pursuant
to the United States inherent right of self-defense,
as reflected in Article 51 of the United Nations
charter.
Biden further explaining that quote, At my
direction.
On February 25th, U.S. forces conducted a
targeted military strike against infrastructure
in eastern Syria used by Iran, supported non-state
militia groups.
Those non-state militia groups were involved
in recent attacks against United States and
coalition personnel in Iraq, including the
February 15 attack in Irbil, Iraq, which wounded
one U.S. service member, wounded four U.S.
contractors, including one critically, and
killed one Filipino contractor.
However.
We are right back to the same issue of a president
obtaining authorization for use of military
force through Congress, this was an issue
with Barack Obama.
This was an issue with Donald Trump.
This is now an issue with Joe Biden.
So there are two things here.
First are the particulars of these strikes.
This is just the latest of 20 years of American
foreign policy all over again since 9/11.
They attacked U.S. personnel in Iraq.
So we're retaliating.
OK, well, so what's the point here?
The point is to send the message that we won't
tolerate this.
All right.
And then what happens next?
The attack sours any goodwill that there was
to the United States.
Nothing improves.
We rinse and repeat for another five years
of the same stuff.
So I don't really care to debate whether this
particular case well, there was a service
member wounded and four contractors and a
Filipino killed.
And so this was justified because of that
attack, to be honest.
Maybe it was under this completely sort of
deranged framework in which we've been operating
for the last 20 years.
Maybe it was justified in that framework.
Maybe it wasn't.
The questions are to, number one, will we
ever have a president who actually dislodges
the decades long status quo of repeating things
that don't work and just extend the status
quo?
This obviously isn't going to do that, regardless
of your opinion about this particular strike.
And then further, we once again get to this
issue of an authorization to use military
force.
This all goes back to resolutions from 2001
and 2002, which were passed to give the president
the ability to go after the then president,
George W. Bush, to go after those who did
the September 11th attacks.
It was used to go into war with Iraq in 2003,
which didn't do the September 11th attacks.
But then it has been subsequently used to
as the legal justification for a whole bunch
of these different strikes, U.S. strikes in
Syria, U.S. strikes elsewhere.
And presidents always point back to the 2001
a yump authorization for the use of military
force as to why they can do it.
But can they?
Many Democrats say no when it's a Democrat
in office.
Many Republicans also say no, although they
tend to shut their mouths when it's a Republican
in the Oval Office doing the same thing.
So we can't be hypocrites here.
If the umph didn't cover Trump stuff in Syria,
didn't cover Obama, didn't cover things George
W. Bush did outside of the scope of responding
to 9/11, it can't cover things that Joe Biden
does either.
So we just have to pick one.
And I believe at this point, 20 years later,
the argument is definitely no good.
So for me, this is beyond any debate about
this particular incident, this particular
bombing.
This is about more of the same once again,
in these never ending conflicts.
And then coinciding with the minimum wage
disaster, Joe Biden included a fifteen dollar
co, rather.
Coinciding with the serious stuff is the minimum
wage disaster.
Joe Biden included a 15 dollar minimum wage
in his covid relief bill on technical grounds.
It's not going to be in the Senate version
of the covid relief bill.
Why?
The Senate parliamentarian Elizabeth McDonough
says a 15 dollar minimum wage provision doesn't
comply with rules governing what can be done
via budget reconciliation.
So almost certainly, even though Kamala Harris
could overrule that decision by the parliamentarian,
the Senate will likely pass a version of covid
relief, not including a 15 dollar minimum
wage.
It'll go back to the house.
The House will have to vote on that and it
will pass without the fifteen dollar minimum
wage.
I don't believe that it's clear that a standalone
bill on a 15 dollar minimum wage makes it
actually happen.
That's increasingly what the Biden administration
is pointing to, saying it's too big a step
to override the Senate parliamentarian.
We are committed to the 15 dollar minimum
wage, but we will do it separately.
I don't know if that will happen.
It's not clear to me that every Democratic
senator wants a 15 dollar minimum wage.
So overall, not a good 48 hour period for
Joe Biden.
And we will, of course, be following this
this week